hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel where today I wanted to show
you what is up with Wolfenstein
Youngblood because this game is kind of
not at all what I thought it would be
maybe that's because I wouldn't kind of
blind and didn't read people's gameplay
previews from e3 because I am such a
huge Wolfenstein fan I'm such a fan of
the new classes and the new order then I
just figured I would love this also I'm
definitely not gonna tell you this game
is bad it's just not what I hoped it
would be by any means so I thought I
would show you guys what it is just so
that people like me who didn't know get
an understanding of what it is so it's
basically like if Wolfenstein was the
division or destiny it's a ludus shooter
that feels like it should be populated
with a lot of people except that it's
co-op it's just you and your sister
where we are right now is the hub world
kind of like a submarine or whatever all
of these people have just nowhere near
as much character as they do in the
other games but they will give you
quests they will have exclamation points
about the heads and will give you a
quest that will be different levels ok
let me show you how destiny this [ __ ] is
this is a series of two duelists daily
weekly and that's a mission replay which
is pretty cool I've accepted these so
that's for example travel 30 kilometers
on foot you get an XP reward of a
thousand and you get 200 coins you want
to know what coins do dog you buy stuff
but basically there are three separate
currencies the one you can see in the
middle of the screen right now is a gold
ball which I am pretty confidently
assuming will be microtransactions which
seems like a very not Bethesda thing to
do down here we have a bunch of
different suits so you can see that that
costs three hundred and fifty gold bars
that's or just pause I don't know what
that called yet even 625 750 that one's
just 10,000 so I guess you can only get
that one with the silver coins but
basically microtransactions in a co-op
game for you to buy suits they're all to
be bought I will mention that you can
pretty quickly get those silver coins
they are affordable or really easy to
find it's not hard to get them but I'm
just surprised they're there at all so
weapons is basically the same thing I
think I've mostly upgraded this one
I can't do this yet that's locked behind
a level cap but all of this stuff does
cost money let's look at it but I
haven't upgraded 360 III 3360 this is
just like it's just crazy to me that
this is in a a Wolfenstein game at all I
really didn't expect it and I just would
have thought this was an T Bethesda
especially when it's a $40 game for it
to focus on this I mean maybe that's how
they justify it maybe that's how it
makes sense let's go with this one
anyway because I do have the cash so I'm
gonna show you what the game itself
actually looks like if I just jump
downstairs this is a map that has my
quests on it
Riverside just has weekly challenges
catacombs is where I am right now
little Boland it's a first district that
I went to has lenses secret that's gonna
be a quest that I can do maybe I will do
that one as an example and then Claude
the Amuro which requires me to find the
underground but is level 20 so I'm not
high enough level to do it I will just
get destroyed by enemies and then a raid
mission for brother 1 and basically the
idea right now is that section the
political detention area full has
another raid mission and then the proto
haand is is it's got a skull on it right
now so it would be way too hot for me to
do where is it saying level 20 I can do
it it'll just be tough because it's
above my level right now what I'm
walking towards as far as the game is
concerned is to level 20 to get this
stuff done there is an opening cutscene
that features BJ that you know builds
into the the narrative but other than
that very little story stuff has
actually happened maybe the first
mission and and this is really the game
so let's jump into Little Bo in let me
just pull out my favorite gun I will say
the combat is awesome I love it it's
faster than the previous games ok let's
take out the spawns of one
okay level 17 okay that's not that bad
he's still tough though
but basically you will keep coming to
these same areas over and over and over
again
looks like enemies off scaling and
difficulty as far as I can tell but uh
again just really not what I expected
it's like a destiny like a division the
enemies respawn every time that you come
oh yeah hey
come down you go come on
all right that's it but okay yeah we
take a nap
yeah rather than it being you know a
scripted true line like the other
Wolfenstein games and some of the
missions have been you know very
uninteresting as they are in games like
that stuff like take out the sixteen
Nazis in this room and I think that
might have even been in the exact same
place so I'm doing this right now so
it's not like you get a ton of variety
out of it either more coins yeah the
silver coins are just sitting around but
they have crates that have a lot of them
okay decoding floppy disks is the thing
you tend to do a lot of as well the
traversal is super fun like I said I
like that you can get through stuff this
way like you can avoid a lot of the
combat because you will be fighting a
lot of the same [ __ ] over and over again
that should've gave me a lot of coins
fifty sometimes you can get like 300
from a crate like that and those crates
aren't that difficult to find I feel
like that's I think worth giving them
credit for I don't really want to fight
these guys so I'm just gonna run cuz
I've already fought them a few times
before obviously it's a good way to
level up but you know we're gonna pause
and this will happen let's do this one
this is an event I've done this one
before it's basically like seems like
they just randomly spawn the just side
quests or actions that pop up while
you're already in a side quest
most of the points that yeah they are
generally pretty simple but just another
thing I would not have expected it was a
bit weird haven't been trouble with that
tree another thing I would not have
expected to show up in a [ __ ] in the
Wolfenstein game it almost feels like
this is them testing the waters to see
if they want to make something like
[ __ ] sake woman something a lot more
multiplayer focused this is the fallout
76 of the Wolfenstein universe I think
just let me put the microphone down see
I got two hundred points for that so
obviously that Alberto is purchasing
this cosmetics I just don't want to die
I know you could I'm just not anywhere
near as interested in the story as I
have been in every other Wolfenstein
which is the real bummer it's another
one another one of those actions showed
up and of course when you run around
environments yeah there's just tons of
stuff scattered around to pick up a lot
of the times oh where is he okay here we
go
we did it we found it I guess it's gonna
take us to the the first boss with us
raid as they call it pretty much the
rest of the game this this is it so I
will finish a quest go back to home base
I'll get XP and money for it that'll
just happen over a period of time and
then usually when I get back to base
there's another mission waiting for me
that is um equally pretty simple but I
guess this one might count as a story
mission because I am heading towards one
of the raids I'm frankly probably not
ready for it you don't know that what
level are you 18 should be all right let
me so that's what I'm doing right now
fine exit to brother one which I wasn't
trying to do so I guess as far as this
level is concerned this plot is probably
what I was building up to and a little
bow in and that the whole goal here is
to take out for the one this is supposed
to be a raid so I'm guessing it's
probably longer and hotter and maybe a
little more interesting university game
so maybe I shouldn't show you the rest
of this part in case you happen to want
to experience this stuff yourself but
yeah I ultimately just wanted to make
this video to explain to you guys what
this game actually is because it is not
what I expected it is not the
Wolfenstein that I'm familiar with which
is fine just not what I expected if you
guys are buying it and of course that's
an important thing to note but like I
said I will have a proper review where I
actually you know talk about the good
than bad points of the game on inside
gaming where this is just me explaining
what kind of game it is which you know
is a whole other thing it does this
every time that you get to it a new part
of the